this episode is sponsored by keeps
gentlemen or ladies i'm not going to
make any assumptions here do you worry
about your hair because did you know
that two out of three guys will
experience some kind of male pattern
baldness by the time they reach 35
[ __ ] well keeps has got you covered
keeps is a subscription service that
helps men keep their hair they offer
clinically proven treatments to combat
the substance of hair loss that are
delivered straight to your door
typically at half the cost of pharmacy
prices and the best part is all of this
is done completely online with keeps you
can get quality expert care without ever
visiting a doctor or pharmacy because
they can find a routine that works for
you whether you're looking to prevent
hair loss stimulating hair growth or
just looking to take better care of your
hair keeps has got you covered because
in addition to all the treatments keeps
has award-winning all-natural thickening
shampoo and conditioner systems so what
are you waiting for keep your hair today
i see what they did there to get 50 off
your first order go to
keeps.com or click the link in the
description that's
k-e-e-p-s com
thank you to keeps for sponsoring me
today and with that said
on with the video
it's late
everyone you know around you is already
dead asleep you look at the clock and
it's 3am but your body for some reason
is still nowhere near tired the only
thing keeping you company are those two
last standing mates in your discord
voice chat you've been sat in for the
last four hours
but even you know they're going to be
packing it in soon there's only so much
fan art you can post games you can
discuss sketching memes you can share
with each other before everyone runs dry
chicken
you know you should be going to sleep
but after feeling stupidly groggy for
most of the day your [ __ ] brain
decides now is the perfect time to be
like hey yo where's the party at yo is
it time to party so since you have
nothing better to do you decide to go
out for a walk and what grease you is
emptiness the streets are quiet the only
sounds you hear are the low hum of the
wind and the odd cricket chirping all
the homes are pitch black office
buildings light up a room full of nobody
street lights illuminate a path to
nothingness the roads which are normally
an area of danger in bustling traffic is
completely empty void of any cars you
can walk in the middle of the road and
no one will give a damn hell you can
walk run or cartwheel your way across
for all you care this is the only time
you own this space no one's gonna shadow
you no one's gonna judge you no one's
gonna uphold the rules this is a time
when you are
free
this is the world that call of the night
takes place in
so here's a little backstory i picked up
this manga one day because i rushed in
the family mart because i needed a clear
file yes it was the one time in my life
had used for a clear file and i didn't
have one of the [ __ ] hundred useless
ones that is sitting in my house so i go
to that section in family mart and i see
a bunch of blank clear files for sale
and then this set and my first thought
was who this [ __ ] the smug grin the
cute little fangs the smug grin the
absolute drip of some of these outfits
the smile that can cure depression the
smug grin this is the kind of face i
should have seen in about 100 different
discord profile pictures by now but yet
i hadn't so turn it over and see that
it's a promotion for you
you're [ __ ] god i hate reading
stylized fans the nazim enclosure to see
that it's written in a language that
even my monkey brain could comprehend
your fukashi no uttar a manga from the
same author as the gashikashi so i
immediately picked up the manga and
started reading more of the story
sometimes i try to curate the finest of
anime and manga based on deep meaningful
stories that look like they can give a
bit of introspection and really impact
the people reading it and sometimes i
pick up something because i see an anime
girl with a [ __ ] eating grin
most of the time it's the latter ko
yamori has insomnia despite being a good
kid with good grades he's dissatisfied
with the school life he lives so one day
he just up and decides [ __ ] it
imma stop going without any
responsibilities or anything to keep him
occupied during the day he can no longer
sleep and so he decides to go on a night
walk where he meets a short sassy young
girl named nazna who invites him to go
back to sleep together cole being a
smart kid immediately remembers what to
say when strange girls dressed like
hookers at midnight ask you to come back
to their place around a dark alleyway
yes nazna though is actually secretly a
vampire so unfortunately for co she
doesn't want to suck dick she only wants
to suck blood cheeky [ __ ] and after
sucking co he's immediately surprised
that he also doesn't turn into one after
talking ko actually wants to become a
vampire he sees the freedom from daytime
responsibilities that nazina has but she
reveals that he can only become a
vampire if the human is actually in love
with the vampire before she sucks his
blood so ko thinks to himself well
guess it's finally time to binge the
entirety of twilight i don't sleep so he
decides to try and fall in love with her
so she can turn him into a vampire even
though by anime rules she's probably
like 30 years old and ko is
14. from the synopsis the series seems
like your typical supernatural anime
romance that's pretty much a diamond
doesn't these days but what really drew
me in about this title was just the
world of nighttime itself you think you
need to get [ __ ] isokai to a fantasy
place with big titty delphicos falling
over your dick to go to another world
[ __ ] no time and you decide to walk back
the exact same route but somewhere along
the way you look up and you think to
yourself
where the [ __ ] am i do these streets
always look like this maybe i took a
wrong turn was there always a mcdonald's
there or where am i tripping what are
these lovecraftian nightmare creatures
wandering around that smell like ten
pints of guinness the real draw-off call
of the night is seeing stories centered
around this setting normally when i hear
stories involving vampires my initial
reaction is always normally
i don't know what it is i just have zero
interest in the general law of vampires
unless it happens to be a six foot lady
who can also step on me
but here they're the perfect vehicle to
tell stories about people that inhabit
the world of night time we see co
meeting different people in the dead of
night we find out their stories and
eventually we meet other vampires who
have their own approaches and beliefs of
what they think it means to be well a
vampire there's just something different
about seeing someone at that time of the
night you're not bound by the same
social shackles you are in the daytime
everything and everyone has a different
pace to them and this is the only manga
i've seen that really conveys that same
feeling of just wandering the streets in
the dead of night one of my favorite
stories is when ko bumps into an
overworked underappreciated office
worker someone working a stressful job
with an [ __ ] boss she finds
connection with ko over the brief
respite she feels from all that during
the night time there's a sense of peace
there that she could never find during
the stressful daytime and after walking
to the convenience store one day when
everyone was already dead asleep she had
a moment to herself when she realized
yeah
i belong here
that was the freedom that she yearned
for in life and the knight was the only
place where she could find it it's just
small stories like this that i found
myself relating to the only thing that
really rubbed me the wrong way overall
was the main character acting like all
these societal responsibilities he had
was so overbearing that he'd rather
blindly become a vampire just to escape
it all like [ __ ] you're 14 years old
the biggest responsibilities you have
are getting your homework in on time try
not to pop your first boner when hannah
from class 9 sits next to you and coming
to terms that eating boogers is no
longer a socially acceptable thing to do
at your age surprisingly though this
does get addressed as the series not
only explores his character but nazner's
as well as the manga progresses we start
to see what it really means to be a
night walker not a vampire per se but a
being where responsibilities mean
nothing when you never have any
engagements you need to wake up for what
does that do to a person now i gotta be
real for a second i'd like to think that
everything i talk about is a 10 out of
10 banger that i could recommend to
anyone and everyone but i mean even i
know there's only so many times i can
recommend domestic girlfriend sometimes
though i just find a series that fits
such a specific niche a small niche that
definitely doesn't appeal to everyone
but definitely does to me at least
youfukashi nuta isn't something that's
going to appeal to everybody or even
most people there's not so much anything
that really grips you about this it's
got some interesting ideas about
relationship depression eroticism and
youth but it's fed to you in such a slow
drip feed that it will definitely put a
lot of people off for me though that
slow pacing is such a big part in how
this story feels it's laid back it's
aloof it's mellow most of the time
exactly like the setting it takes place
in holy [ __ ] did i just become a slice
of life man [ __ ] nighttime
because if there's one thing this manga
does beyond characters or story or
romance or themes that i can't find
anywhere else it's the vibe this series
emanates and this is the niche that i'm
talking about i'm a responsible adult
now who tries to have a healthy sleeping
schedule going to bed and waking up at a
responsible times because if i don't i'm
just not going to get any work done god
it's so boring adulting but you know
what for most of my life i've always
been a night owl i've never had trouble
staying awake and part of the reason for
this was because most of my friends were
online living in america so my social
time would generally be later than usual
anyway but also there was just something
so calming and soothing about the
peacefulness of night i found comfort
knowing that most of society was asleep
there was no pressure to be active or
productive because no one is you could
just walk the empty streets and immerse
yourself in the quietness you felt this
slight kinship to any random stranger
you'd see what's their story why are
they out in the dead of night what led
them to this time and place that really
no one like me
should be awake finding comfort in the
dead of night reminds me of a time when
responsibilities aren't constantly
crawling up at you you're not stressing
over something you have to be awake
early for you don't have any commitments
you need to worry about you can just do
whatever you want and no one's going to
be there to stop you this is what i felt
when i read this manga there wasn't
anything hugely gripping that kept me
coming back but it was just the comforts
that only other fellow night owls out
there would be able to understand that's
not to say that there isn't any plot or
character development at all but what i
am trying to say is it ain't the cheese
or the tomato base of the pizza it's
just the extra little toppings you find
on top so then you may be wondering
what's the crust to this story
[ __ ] off you know the appeal is niche
enough that i'm honestly a bit surprised
the thing already has an anime coming
out next summer
i've never seen anyone even mention this
name let alone talk about this manga but
yet the pv already has 4.1 million views
which you know what just look at the
thumbnail you know exactly why this got
4.1 million views
look i'm calling it now we're about to
get a huge rush of anime profile
pictures with nazna front and center
because i swear to god she's got the
perfect face built for it it's one of
those series where i'm sure the anime
can get decently popular enough with a
small but dedicated fan base that i
already can't wait for that
cool fan arts we're going to see of her
not to mention we're even getting an
opening from creepy nuts
famous brother of dies it's been a while
since i've just gone out of my way to
blindly give a new title a try without
any recommendation without any prior
knowledge without any preconceptions and
you know what it was a wonderful
experience maybe i've just found the
optimal recommendation system for new
anime and manga that no one has yet
discovered hey how do you find new anime
to watch oh you know i just see what's
popular and mal or something and what do
you use yeah i just uh see what some
[ __ ] youtuber recommends what do you
use then family mart clear files
get on my level
hey guys hope you enjoyed that video
thank you very much too alpha sigma
basil dysfunctional degenerate payne
patchett elephant ivido jeff levardos
pony stark the walton and everyone else
my patreon for helping to support me for
this month and making this video
possible alright guys i'm just going to
say it now
this is the last gig up video of 2021 so
i know in previous years i've tried to
make an end of year video come out
before the new year but i've kind of
given up on that right now because that
gave me an unholy amount of work to do
in the holiday season and i think i'm
just kind of beyond that right now but
that doesn't mean i'm not gonna be
making content because i'm going to be
using this extra time to stream a bit
more and also upload my second channel
if you didn't know i have a second
channel now that i'm going to be
uploading more on so if you want to see
that you can follow me on twitch.tv
and also my second channel god
that's not a misspelling i swear to god
you will be getting some kind of 2021
anime video but that's going to be
coming in 2022 it's probably gonna be
another best of 2021 anime video since i
think it's kind of impossible for me to
like encompass all of anime right now
because there's just so much but you're
definitely gonna be getting something so
i guess the next time i'm gonna see you
on this channel is in 2022. so until
then i hope you have a merry christmas
or happy holidays if you don't celebrate
christmas i hope you have a fantastic
new year and until then i've been gig uk
and i'll see you all next time